how can I ask you to take take your
seats please thank you very much
I'm just going to do the uh pre meeting
announcement but there are no planned
fire drills so if the alarm goes off
please leave a building in an orderly
fashion through the nearest fire exit
please use either the fire exit through
the main doors off a hall or the fire
exit in the store room adjacent to the
stage
the fire assembly point is the island in
front of the main entrance to the
building
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by Council staff
please note that the meeting will be
live streamed
please switch off mobiles or turn them
to silence
and please note that toilets and hand
washing facilities are in the foyer area
[Music]
so with you all please be upstanding to
receive the chairman the Chairman's
chapel and the chief executive
it is uh my final visit to you today the
year has gone so very quickly hasn't it
my mum used to say the older you get the
quicker it goes I think she was right uh
but it has been a real privilege for me
to be Chaplin to Mike but more
importantly to be praying for you as
elected members by the public to
represent them in the arena of the
political movements in our areas so this
will be my final evening with you and
I'm staying to listen and see what goes
on so hopefully you'll be on your best
behavior this evening
and I'm going to pray for you before we
begin
so let us pray
almighty God we bring before you the
agenda for tonight's meeting
that we who have been entrusted with the
responsibility to govern and make
decisions for those who have elected us
will be guided by the best of motives
and with the interests of all for the
benefit of all
we ask that you would give us clear
minds and the desire to hear all points
of view including those who may be
diametrically opposed to our own
we pray for openness in our debate
make us gracious and courteous to friend
an opponent alike with a real sense of
working together for this district and
the areas that are represented by each
of our district councilors
the same time Lord we commend for your
blessing the work of all the employees
of Rochford District Council
who maintain Implement and make possible
the words that are debated discussed and
formed into policy
this we asked in Jesus name
amen
Margaret say the Lord's Prayer and if
you know the words and would like to
join in then please do so
Our Father which art in heaven Hallowed
be thy name thy kingdom come thy will be
done in earth as it is in heaven give us
this day our daily bread and forgive us
our trespasses as we forgive them that
trespass against us
and lead us not into temptation but
Deliver Us from Evil for thine is the
kingdom the power and the glory forever
and ever amen
and finally a prayer for Mike
Lord we thank you for his witness and
his work we thank you for his commitment
and pray now that he would know your
blessing as he passes the mantle over
and we pray for his successor that they
too would work for the good of all we
ask this in Jesus name
and the blessing of God Almighty the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit be
with you all and all whom you love this
night and forevermore
amen
thank you very much thank you it won't
be the last we shall see each other
we're working very hard to find a way to
get rid of the bats in your Belfry oh
thank you
members please be seated
[Music]
I'd like to welcome you all to Rochford
District council's annual council
meeting can I please take this
opportunity working in all the new
elected members of the to the Council on
this first formal rupture district
council meeting of this Municipal year
Council booth
councilor Mrs Brewer Council London
councilor Elliot Mason and councilor Mrs
page
I would like to welcome all those
re-elected members and all other member
count members Council officers and
members of the public who are joining
this evening
I would like to say farewell
to all those councilors who are no
longer serving as counselors
following this year's election
and that was counselor Tony truck Carter
councilor lamley councilor Rowe
councilor Webb and councilor Wilkinson
and thank them for their service to the
council and to the Rochford to the
residents of Rochford District
members when I invite you to speak
please ensure you have the microphone in
front of you before speaking in as the
microphones are needed for the hearing
Loop and for the live stream
they're all switched on
for you to speak so you do not need to
adjust them
but members you need to switch them on
you have a button in front of you and
the chairman has the privilege he does
have a mute button as well so you are
warned
given the size of the room and a number
of us present when you wish to speak or
vote can you please raise your hand
clearly and as I said before like when
you were at school
high in the air
so it can easily be seen by all and
leave it up until you have asked to
lower it
members of the public
while you are of course entitled to film
or take photographs during this meeting
can I please emphasize to do that you
should be should be done within without
disruption
to the meeting I know can only be done
for the designated area in the public
seating
can I there please therefore ask if you
would raise your hand clearly in the air
if you wish to take photographs or film
this evening
thank you
okay
that moves us on to item one
to elect the chairman
for the count for the council with a 20
23-24 musical year
people
um I believe councilor Hoya
yes thank you chairman I'd like to
nominate councilor Jack Norman to the
role of chairman
and do you have a second now
[Music]
okay thank you
right members
those members in favor please raise your
hand clearly in the air and keep them
there until I ask you to lower them
those in favor
thank you
okay
please love your hands
foreign
please raise your hand clearly in the
air keep them up until I ask you to know
them
goes against
thank you members
those members wish him to abstain please
raise your hand
thank you members hello and
okay members
that's 4 22. abstain 13.
can I ask councilor Lawman
to join me
[Applause]
foreign
thank you
thanks I want to thank you
remember can I just take first with this
opportunity to thank everybody for
voting for me for those that didn't stay
for not going against
it I'll tell you that as unanimous but
thank you very much and I hope that my
performance over the coming year will be
uh exactly you expected and I will
present myself with honor towards this
Council thank you very much
foreign
having been elected to the office of
chairman of the Council of the District
of Romford declare that I take this
office Roxford
it's why it's written
and these are all listening
of Rochford I declare that I take this
office upon myself and we're duly have
Faithfully fulfilled the duties of it
according to the person of my judgment
and ability I undertake to observe the
code of as to the conduct which is
expected of members of the Rochford
District Council dated the 25th of May
2023. thank you
thank you
[Music]
I'd like to take this opportunity now to
make uh thanks to our chair past
chairman councilor Mike stepped over the
work he's carried out this year he's
done an absolutely slightly job a superb
job and I'm grateful for the leadership
that he's shown to this cancer over the
proceeding year I'd like to take the
opportunity now to present him with a
pasture
thank you very much it is a recognition
of the work that you're carried out and
you deserve every part of it thank you
[Music]
thank you very much congratulations
thank you if any member wishes to make a
comment
[Music]
s
thank you
[Music]
they're very sensitive these microphones
ladies and gentlemen
Steve colleagues
and members of our community
it's a strange job you vote yourself in
and then you vote yourself out
so it is a bit of a strange look
today is my chairman of chairman comes
to an end
I stand before you with mixed emotions
it's a bit of Bittersweet moment filled
with gratitude for The Incredible
Journey
we are
shared any a touch of sadness as a bid
farewell to the role
that I've been an honor and a privilege
to fulfill
I reflect upon my year in office
and are filled with a sense of pride
and or at the collective achievement we
are celebrating
what a year it's been
you could never have
actually predicted
some of the events that were going to
happen
this year has marked a significant
milestone
and showed our community and touch their
hearts
the Jubilee celebrations
Testament to her during spirit
and unity allowed us to come together
enjoy celebration
and Jack I will just comment it's
amazing the number of places you can gay
crash wearing the chain
I did it on the Jubilee and I ended up
in all sorts of places
so you're with Megan then yes
[Music]
however in the midst of our Jubilee
festivals
where you experience the loss and
passing of our bit of a queen
it was a moment of great sadness and
reflection
and we move on the loss of a remarkable
so
a remarkable leader who embody Grace
dedication
an unwavering commitment to our nation
together we found support comfort and
strength
during the time of grief
and we eagerly anticipated the new
King's coronation the historic event
filled our hearts
with hope excitement and renew of a
sense of purpose
members was going off script
if you think about it we had a jubilee
I then attended Two Gun salutes one of
for the death of the queen and then
another one to announce that the new
king
I don't still amazed how they kept count
of all then gunshots going off without
missing any
we've then had three prime ministers and
Counting
and five chancellors and Counting
[Music]
we then had to read the proclamation for
the new king
and believe you me I can't thank
the team behind the scenes can't see
where Holly is and all the work they put
into doing that
we didn't get the final the final
script
until I think it was the afternoon
before
there's quite a lot of words in there
but I've never used before
then we caused Taiwan
to the coronation
and everything else who could have
predicted that was going to happen only
one year
today I wish to celebrate the
compliments of our community the
countless individuals businesses and
organizations that have rallied together
to create a lasting impact
it is your resilience
your passion
and your unwavering support have brought
us where we are today
Jeremiah tenure as chairman I've been
privileged to witness incredible powers
of community in action
to mention a couple of events that I've
attended
one was at Swain school was a Hindu and
it was described to me as the Hindu
Harvest Festival
very very colorful all the ladies were
very sorry
and I've never seen such well organized
chaos
believe me there were so many things
going on at the same time it was
unbelievable
and then towards the end
the biggest kind of musical chairs I've
ever seen
there was a hundred ladies in sarees all
sat down for a game of musical chairs
absolutely unbelievable
the other event that I attended
was not too far from here
was the church just opposite the
entrance of George's Park here
church had been recently taken over
by
uh
a Christian group which stems from
Nigeria
when I arrived I was dressed as you see
me now with the chain
and as we arrived everybody was dressed
in pure white
from the hats to their shoes everything
and of course I stood out like a sore
thumb I'd do the best of times with the
chain and everything else
and just to save any confusion
they also presented me with this
just because they forgot who I was
[Music]
if anybody wants the chance to go and
see them get along with Eastwood Road
there and there'd be more than welcome
you on a Sunday Sunday morning for their
services
I stepped down from this role
and I'm grateful for the trust that you
have replacing me
for the opportunity to serve alongside
the remarkable individuals individuals
and the countless movements
of inspiration and calibration
together we have demonstrated that when
Community unites behind a common purpose
there is no limit to what can be
achieved
as we embark on a new chapter
I'm confident our community community
will continue to thrive
Guided by the principles of compassion
unity and progress
I have every faith in our incoming
chairman
whose leadership and dedication will
undoubtedly prepare us to even greater
Heights
together we will continue to build a
community
that is inclusive violent
and filled with the boundless
opportunities for all
I'd also like to thank you for my for
the support
to my charities
which were trust linked
and achievement through football
both very much
for the Youth and the younger people in
mind
they are the ones that are going to
replace us
in the East Farm
and we need to make sure they have the
right start
I'm not a charity and I have the honor
tomorrow to present the church to the
two charities
which are trustling
and achievements through football
I've been very privileged to be able to
say that we've raised seven thousand
347 pound and 90p
so thank you
[Applause]
that comes from all the support you have
made in attending events of various
things not forgetting the chief exec
trip up a number of hills
over a period
forget how many heels it actually was
now
in closing I would like to express my
deepest thanks
to each and every one of you
thank you for your unwavering support
your commitment to our community and
your belief in in a future filled with
hope and possibility
it has been great to serve as your chair
May our community come to thrive and
Inspire the generations to come
members members of the public thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you
before you go just opening to the
members if they wish to make any
comments
[Music]
councilor Lawman uh firstly can I be one
of the first to congratulate you on your
appointment uh I am sure that your
appointment tonight puts right uh
something that you didn't quite achieve
a few years ago uh and uh time has
caught up and perhaps that's now put it
right so I sincerely wish you a good
year uh it's an honor and a privilege I
know that you particularly feel uh in
the opportunity to represent botram
District Council and I'm sure you'll do
it uh With Honor passion and good faith
and everything else we wish you wish you
well uh turning to the ex-german uh
councilor stecto you have represented
this District well in the last year
again with passion with enthusiasm
dedication and impartiality which is the
Chairman's role actually to make sure
that fairness is done all around and I
know that's been a key aspect that
you've as one of the real real passions
that you've had certainly I wish you
well
um as you rejoin the ranks of the
conservative group back here uh and uh
thank you very much indeed for your time
thank you both
are there any other members that wish to
make coming councilor Mrs Mason
thank you
cheers chair for the first time Council
so I'm sure you're going to enjoy your
year and I'm sure it's going to be a
very interesting one and we welcome you
to the Post
I'd also like to express on behalf I'm
sure of my group and I'm sure
other members here that aren't perhaps
in my group The thanks to council's
Steptoe for the fairness and the
directness and the way that he's
conducted the last year it's always
difficult
for a party that is small and we like
the respect that you've shown us thank
you it was appreciated and all the best
for the future
there have been other members thank you
for helping the first to congratulations
on your way out
thank you
have a good year thank you thank you so
much
members will now take item three
um to elect the vice chairman of the
council for the
2023-2024 ensuing year Municipal year
do I have any nominations
[Music]
I nominate councilor
page
do we have a second
football
thank you chairman I'd like to second
that nomination
thank you
they're members we have a proposition
there'd be no other nomination to have a
proposition to elect councilor Paige as
Vice chairman with all those in favor
please raise your hands and keep them up
until told to take them down
but without you in favor
so the thank you members to the contrary
if any
no
any abstentions
their members that emotions carried is
22-4 zero against and 13 abstinctions so
therefore declare cancer serum page Vice
chairman if you'd like to come this way
please
foreign
[Music]
yeah I would just like to thank
everybody very very much for your
support and to elevating me into such a
privileged and honored situation it's
very humbly before me and I'm looking
very much forward to working and serving
our beautiful Community
thank you
okay
[Music]
yeah I know
I Sarah Jane page having been elected to
the office of Vice chairman of the
Council of the District of Rochford
declare that I take that office upon
myself and will Julie and Faithfully
fulfill the duties of it according to
the best of my judgment and ability
undertake to observe the code as to the
conduct which is expected of members of
Rochford District Council
[Music]
thank you very much
I'd like to give a big thanks to Joe
McPherson the outgoing Vice chairman and
um very grateful for the very hard work
that she's put in this year with Mike
Steptoe and may ask you at this point
Mike to say a few words about Joe for us
please
thank you
[Music]
thank you chairman
um Joe sadly can't be with us here this
evening but she asked me to read out a
message from her
um but first of all I would just like to
say thank thanks thanks to her put it on
record of all the support that she's
given me in particular
um through my year as chairman I
couldn't have asked for a better Vice
chairman
these are Joe's words
and I read from what she has has given
me here
my year as Vice chairman certainly gave
me Clarity on how very hard the role is
at four Council meetings
but the other side of the role
represented in Rochester council at
events was an absolute honor
I attended many events on behalf of
Rochford Council and to name just a few
Awards hearing the achievements of young
people from the district
South End University Awards
Southeast Essex schools Music Festival
the Lions Club disability Sports Bank
many charity events including mencap
trust links
carers care
the Holocaust Memorial Day
representing RDC on Remembrance Day
the sad loss of our beloved Queen
and a proclamation of the new king
and most recently
even song to celebrate the coronation of
the king at Chelmsford Cathedral
I hope everywhere everyone feels that
Ryan took undertook the role well in
supporting Mike in this year in his year
as chairman
I would say Syria have loved to have
been chairman this will use civil year
alas that is not to be
I wish the incoming chairman well
and to all members old and new in
addition
to the seven Nolan principles of public
life
please remember
to add a little kindness
be kind to fellow members
officers and to yourself
they're her words Jim thank you
yes it would take a gender item five
which is the Chapman for the full coming
year I will I haven't sorted out I won't
announce any decision on that at the
next meeting
agenda item six apologies for Access
absence I have received apologies from
cancer Mrs McPherson councilor Myers and
councilor sharp are there any other
absentees Council Hawaii thank you
chairman yes councilor Tracy Knight
any others
thank you
uh item seven on the agenda to approve
the meetings held on the 15th of
February 2023 and the 21st of February
2023 all been circulated
um can I members would you please
approve the the minutes are you all in
agreement
thank you I see that passed item eight
announcers for the chairman and Ohio pay
the service there are none there for the
chief executive
um
I will again uh my charity because I was
only sort of like notified rather
quickly so I have an organized Charities
at the moment but I have got that in
place and hopefully that again will be
announced in the next meeting
and I hope I could do as well as
counselor step though or better
[Laughter]
item nine to elect the leader of the
council for a four-year period
when we do this can the members please
hold their hands up clearly so that uh
they could be counted and put them down
when to told to do so
do we have any nominations
occasionally Newport
thank you chairman um I'm sorry may I
take the opportunity to congratulate you
chairman on your new position
um chairman
um I have great pleasure to nominate
councilor John Mason for leader of the
council
do we have a second though
I have also great pleasure in seconding
Council of John Mason thinking position
of leader of the council no other
nominations
we have a nomination of counselor John
Mason for leader of the council for the
forthcoming term all as you favor
the UK
can't push in all these buttons
well I'll play a piano when I finished
here
um right any to the country
any abstentions
members we have 22 4 Nano games and 13
abstentions our near thought declare
that proposition carried character icing
if you wish to say something
please chairman
I've got a few sheets of paper
chairman can I also like all the others
welcome you and congratulate you for
your role as chairman of the council
on a personal note I would like to say
what an amazing honor it is to be chosen
to serve the council and residents in
this role
on behalf of the council I would like to
thank councilor Simon Wooten for his
Services leader to the council and
Roswell District thank you Simon
for the next part I am speaking on
behalf of the four groups
which will be working together in a
joint Administration for a Rockford
District Council
independent and green
liberal Democrats
Russia District Independence
Rochford District residents
over the last two weeks assisted by
Jonathan Stevenson Emily Ewell and Steve
Summers on technical matters the group
leaders have worked very diligently to
together to create an agreement which is
referred to as the memorandum of
understanding between the groups
I'm sure at this point I have to think
of a past counselor and I think of the
late councilor Chris black who was a
great friend of mine and others in the
chamber
he shared this ambition
that we're embarking upon as a joint
Administration
and I am sure he would be very very
pleased and proud of the achievement the
team that has put together the mou as we
now call it
um for the administration a new
administration of the council
the agreed mou
has as a matter of courtesy being
provided to the leaders of those groups
that are not part of the joint
Administration and I also included
councilor Joe McPherson in that
I am now going to refer to the most
important parts
of the mou but a full copy will be
circulated to all members of the council
within the minutes of this annual
council meeting
the groups will work together in a
spirit of trust fairness and mutual
cooperation for the benefit of the
residents of Rockford
this includes a commitment to acting in
good faith to maintaining constructive
dialogue to be being open to Alternative
views
and to being inclusive in sharing
information with each other
democracy sits at the heart of this
working together arrangement
with politically
representative decision making and
meaningful public engagement openness
and transparency will be a priority for
the joint Administration
this working arrangement will avoid
creating unnecessary you know
bureaucracy and enable engagement of all
councils allowing for property based on
issues where there is a genuine
disagreement whilst assessing the rapid
progress of council business where
consensus exists
The Joint Administration is committed to
implementing our committee system style
of governance
from May 2024.
subject to the proof of the council
later in this this meeting
during the 23 24 Municipal year the
judge Administration will continue to
operate the leader and executive form of
governance but it will be preparing for
transition to a committee governance
system
by Collective discussion an agreement
the executive will be made up as follows
Deputy leaders of the council councilor
Michael Hoy and councilor James Newport
there will be executive League members
that is the new name for portfolio
holders
the executive lead members in
alphabetical order
councilor Jim krippz counselor at Adrian
Eaves councilor Julie Gooding councilor
Lisa Newport
councilor Chris Stanley councilor Arthur
Williams and councilor Vilma Wilson
I welcome you all to the executive
allocation of lead members for specific
functions will replace the portfolio
holder system
there will be no delegated
decision-making authority to the lead
members and all decisions will be made
collectively by the executive
there's a great deal more in the mou the
memorandum understanding and as I said
earlier it will be circulated in full
and transparently to all members of the
council with the minutes of this meeting
thank you chairman
thank you for the opportunity to speak
and introduce the new Administration to
the council
[Applause]
oration you wish to speak
thank you chair yes um
well I think I want to congratulate my
husband
but I wasn't going to do that was her
will but firstly in one more serious
note
I would like to Echo the thanks Express
to council Wootton and all his group
for their hard work
whilst change can be unsettling it
should be seen in a positive light and I
would like to thank councilor John Mason
for accepting the role as leader of
administration
I'm sure that under his leadership
works for District Council will be
effective during this difficult
transition period
now I obviously didn't share with John
because I'm going to say the memorandum
of the article of understanding States
that democracy sits at the heart
of this working together agreement I
think that's a very important concept
and also to enable the engagement of all
councilors
allowing a proper debate
I trust that we will all and I do mean
all
work together respectfully in a positive
inclusive and constructive way for the
benefit of the community we all love and
serve
so thank you to the outgoing leader and
the incoming leader thank you
good
thank you very much indeed Mr chairman
and thank you both to councilor Mrs
Christine and Mr John Mason uh for your
kind words so much appreciated and
you'll be pleased to know that I haven't
got lots of piece of paper so it'll be
fairly short but congratulations
I think you know already it's a tough
job
the simple fact is that is what
leadership is all about
um and
it's a privilege at the same time as was
said earlier uh to be the leader of this
great Council
um
I think you know you can that's it's
that expression you can please some of
the people some of the time but very
definitely you can't please all of the
people all of the time and I think you
know that already
but
one thing that you will find in this
Spirit of comrade chip
um is that we will be an opposition uh
that will be constructive
we will be challenging and we will work
with you where we feel able to work but
we will hold the administration to
account which is what oppositions should
do
but what I would say in my time as
leader
we had two or three occasions where uh
very serious all our decisions are
serious but I think about the
partnership with Brentwood
and uh we all came together for the good
of the council it was a unanimous vote
uh to work and there's been one or two
like that and actually I think the
strength of this Authority is when we do
feel able to come together in that way
so you have my personal assurance that
as a group we will work with the new
Administration uh we wish you well and
thank you very much indeed for your kind
words thank you Mr chairman thank you
[Music]
a gender item 10 district and Parish
Council election results are these
notifications sorry just had indicated
to talk I might be a bit far away for
people to see I'm sorry I apologize I
didn't see
did you wish to speak
thank you chairman I'll get a flag in
future
um I did just want to say a few words on
this occasion because I think it's very
important
um it's on a personal level
and on a a public level as well
it when I first joined this Council in
2010 Sonia in her wisdom decided to sit
me next to counselor John Mason
um
and I've sat next to him for very many
years shaking his head that was a bad
choice
um ever since that time I've considered
him a friend
um
I think in that time John I think there
were six opposition members and maybe 33
conservatives so I know this has been a
long time coming for you because you
were there a long time before me
and um
I just want to say that I know that John
will prove to be a
a great inspiring leader for this
Council
and I know it's going to be hard and I'm
aware that councilor Mrs Belton brought
up something I sent in the last budget
meeting about we may been your position
this time and it's not as it we might
think it's easy from the opposition side
but we know it's not it's hard and I
just want to Echo that again
um finally
I just want to ask the public and save
the milk campaign in particular
to hold us to account in the same way
they held the former Administration to
account
thank you
no one else wish to speak I do apologize
that Council I just didn't see your hand
right okay they will take an item
changing the district and Parish
election results
are these noted members
okay item 11. notice of group membership
are these noted
right item 12 appointment executive and
committees I would invite the council as
monitoring officer Mr hankin to
introduce item 12 on appointments to the
executive and committees for 2023-2024.
so this is item 12 on your agenda and
it's the appointment of the executive
committees for
2023-24 with regard to the executive our
leader has given the the names of the
members who are the executive and I'm
sure for our Perfect Details uh they
will follow in the future so now we can
turn our attention to the Committees and
the council is asked to conclude to
constitute an agree with allocation of
seats uh with the terms of reference
Center Independence one and to appoint
the membership of committees and to
appoint the chairman and vice chairman
of committees to a point in Armed Forces
uh Covenant champion
now there are a number of votes to be
taking here and what the chairman has
asked me to do is to actually conduct
the vote itself but he will then
announce the results
so if I can take you to the first
recommendation itself which is that the
Committees be constituted as set out in
appendix one uh to this report uh would
can I have a proposal and a second year
for that please
and then this is a very simple vote of
again it will be four against and of
saints so can I ask for those who voting
for to raise a hand please
no
um
I'm good
foreign
thank you
guys I remember
voting against
and any abstentions
okay
this is the original
s
we think there's an error in the
document this was the original document
it was slightly altered
thanks for Christine Mason could you
share that with us please what do you
think a good thought to me
husband
I'm sorry I didn't hear you
yeah yeah can you tell us what the area
is please
um some of the seats were altered and
the chart was ordered and that new chart
came round
I believe
[Music]
thank you
can we just take a five minute Journal
yeah we're just suggesting we're having
a short joke for this little
Administration is sorted there we go get
it right yeah thank you
okay so it's an opportunity if anybody
wants to take a quick break for
ablutions or something
thank you
[Laughter]
remember if you could take your seats
please we'd like to reconvene the
maintain
your options
thank you members at the time now Five
and Twenty to nine declare was back in
action and I'd like to put it back to um
Sonia if I make this
members thank you thank you for your
patience
um as you'll appreciate
um with a lot of this uh information was
you know it's quite sort of late so
there have been lots of discussions
going on with group leaders and um if
you look at the uh table appendix one on
page 12.5 of your reports
um scroll down to uh the licensing and
appeals committee
um as a result of discussions amongst
group leaders the Rochford District
residents
um uh for licensing and appeals they
have swapped a seat with the with the
non-grouped members so the three uh for
Rochester District resident goes down to
two and the uh the non-group member seat
goes up to one okay
then if you look next at overview in
scrutiny
um the independent and green group have
swapped one seat again with a non-group
member so their number for overgoing
security goes down from two to one and
the non-group member gains a seat and
then finally if you look at the
standards committee Rochford District
residents have swapped a seat
again within yeah with a non-greet
member so the number of seats for
Rochester District residents goes up
from one to two and the non-group member
has done from one to zero seed hopefully
that clarifies chairman
thank you so has anybody got any
questions and or didn't pick that up was
any any points to say on that before we
start Council amazing
German
um I'm grateful to you and all the
members for for getting involved in
sorting out that inadvertent error
um we you had taken a vote chairman but
you hadn't declared it can I assume you
will now take a fresh vote
can't you mention I would I would expect
that to be done I believe that too
angry
but generally so if we can now go to the
vote again so it is as we amended
appendix one with those uh figures that
Sonia has just written out and uh I
asked for members who are for uh that
recommendation please
all right
and against
and any abstentions
members the figures are 33 for Neil
against and one abstention so that that
is carried and thank you very much for
your understanding thank you
Kevin if I can now turn to uh the second
recommendation but members be appointed
to serve on committees for the
2023-24 municipal year and this is as
set out in item 12 addendum one and I am
able to announce that the figures in
here are as in the revised appendix one
so there is a no no issue with regards
to that and to that end uh I would
suggest but we have just the one vote on
this as we would normally do and uh
chairman if you're happy I'll now
conduct that vote and it is uh that with
regards to that appendum there about the
addendum that members be appointed to
serve on committees for the 2002-23
municipal year as set out at Agenda One
and the members can I ask those in favor
of peace
okay
we got four
foreign
[Laughter]
thank you
thank you chairman if I could now turn
to a recommendation free
about the chairman and vice chairman of
committees be appointed for the 2003
24th I'm sorry 2023 24 year and this is
our set out in addendum two to item 12.
now uh members and and chairman there
are a number of nominations here and
therefore I would just like to explain
for the first uh committee where we have
two nominations that the voting
procedure is that each member has one
vote
and there are two members who are here
and I'll read their names out in a
minute and you'll be asked to vote for
the first member or to vote for the
second member and then I'll ask for
extensions after that
so the nominations
this is for the audit committee the
nominations for chairman
our councilor Mrs L a butcher
and councilor R Milne
so I will now ask for uh votes in favor
of Mrs L a butcher so folks in favor of
four of Mrs L a butcher Butcher
um
like members and now folks in favor of
counselor R Milne
and finally over any abstentions
the votes are 13 for councilor butcher
22 for cash the meal uh no extensions
and no objections and therefore
councilor Milne wins that
um
thank you chairman if I can remain with
your committee but now we're looking at
nominations for the vice chairman
again we have two nominations of those
are councilor Mrs L.A butcher
and cancer s a Wilson and again iOS for
votes in turn for each of those followed
by extensions so the first first vote is
for councilor Mrs L.A butcher those in
favor
and now those in favor of councilor S.A
Wilson
I'm sorry
and are there any extensions
Wilson 22 therefore Mrs Wilson has to
vote
Julie Electric
hello I'm really sorry Joe it's not me
it's the um other councilor Wilson
oh sorry
you have yes I do apologize yeah
I'm about to go watch on there I'm sorry
thank you Jay if I can now turn to the
chief officer appointments committee
there is one nomination for chairman and
that is councilor J.E Newport so can I
ask for both in favor
mm-hmm
foreign against
any abstentions
remember it says 22 for three
abstentions and none again so that
motion is carried
thank you chairman so the same committee
chief officer appointments we have one
nomination for vice chairman
and that is councilor Mrs J.R Gooding
again can I ask for uh members four
please
thank you
[Music]
against
and abstentions
thank you
members the result there it says 26 4 no
objections and nine abstentions
therefore that motion has been carried
thank you chairman if I can turn to the
development committee again we have two
nominations here so I'll renate the
names of both each member has one vote
uh the two nominations are for cancer ah
Eaves and councilor Mrs L Shaw and I
will come with to uh councilor a h Eaves
first and as for those in favor
yeah
I know members of those in favor of
councilor Mrs L Shaw
thank you
and then the abstentions
[Music]
remember the results are casually is 23
cancer Mrs Shore 10 two extensions no
objections and therefore cancer Reeves
is due to the elected
thanks Evan if I can turn to the vice
chairman for the development committee
again for our two nominations I'll read
it both names first and then ask for
votes
thanks for dsfd and councilor Mrs V A
Wilson
and I will go to the councilor dsfdfirst
and both four
and now both in favor of cancer and Mrs
V A Wilson
did you get there
and are there any abstentions
no thank you members as councilor SD 13
cancer Mrs V Mrs Wilson uh 22 therefore
Mrs Wilson is nominated
chairman this is for the licensing and
appeals committee again there are two
nominations these are for cancer dsfd
and councilor R Lamborn
can I ask first for councilor dsfd those
four
and they'll counselor R Lamborn those
and any extensions
hello
so the vote the results are canceled
fd13 Council lamp on 22 therefore
Council Lamborghini Wednesday let that
vote thank you thank you
chairman of our two nominations for the
vice chairman of the licensing appeals
committee and those are a Cancer a g
cross and councilor Mrs L Shaw
so I'll go to counselor a g cross those
four
and Mrs L Shaw those four
and are there any abstentions
[Laughter]
members the vote is cashed across 22
which cancer not sure which is Shaw's 13
near broadcast across
[Music]
playing a chairman eternity V overview
is scrutiny committee again we have two
nominations
those offer thanks to Mrs D.L Belton and
Mrs J.E McPherson
if I deal with councilor Mrs D.L Belton
first those in favor
and now for Mrs J.E McPherson those in
favor
thank you
and any abstentions
one of the members the result there is
is Mrs Belton they've council Mrs
belton's 11. councilor Mrs McPherson 23
and one abstention therefore Council
McPherson Windsor
thank you chairman we now turn to the
vice chairman of overview and scrutiny
again there are two nominations
thanks for MJ booth and councilor Mrs
E.P Gadsden if I turn to counselor NJ
booth at first those in favor
and Mrs EP Gadsden those in favor
and are there any obsessions
the result of that vote is cancer both
22 against the Gladstone 13 so against
the booth wins that one
thank you
thank you chairman
this is for the planning policy
committee nomination for chairman we
only have one
that is for counselor J.E Crips so can I
ask for members four please
thank you
against
and abstentions
membership 32 for true abstentions and
uh no objections that's the missions
thank you chairman now for the vice
chairman of a planning policy committee
one nomination that is counselor m j
step tool so can I ask for members four
[Applause]
foreign
against
and abstentions
33 4 2 extensions
and no none against so cancer receptor
you win that moment thank you
thank you chairman we now turn to the
standards committee we have two
nominations for chairman
and those are gangster DJ sparing and
councilor Mrs d p Squires and Coleman I
will turn to councilor DJ sparing DJ
sparing first and ask for those in favor
and when I go to counselor Mrs DP
Squires Coleman and ask for those in
favor
thank you
and are there any abstentions
the voter says okay it's just very in 13
councilor Mrs Squires Coleman 22 so Mrs
Squires Coleman Winslet mode
here and I know turn to the vice
chairman for the standards committee
there is one nomination
that is for councilor rcd Linden can I
ask those in favor
against
and abstentions
thank you very much so 4 28 5 against
was absolutely
and none against so Council Indian wins
that
I'm sure when we come to the uh final
committee and this is for the statutory
officer Personnel committee the one
nomination for chairman is councilor Mrs
C M Mason
and may I have members of four
against
oh
then the abstentions
[Laughter]
I remember 32 for three abstentions
um so can some Mason Mrs Mason with
leopard
chairman we have one nomination for the
vice chairman of this Saturday officer
Personnel committee and that is
councilor Essie wooden may I ask for uh
votes for
against
and abstentions
3243 abstentions
the chairman that takes me to the last
recommendation
thank you thank you chairman oh that's
louder
um just just a point as we come on to
the next item a question that was raised
and regarding our Armed Forces um
champion
it was considered could this be a joint
position
um councilor butcher has represented the
council for a number of years and he's
extremely passionate about the about the
Armed Forces councilor Stuart Wilson
would also be a fantastic Ambassador for
this Council given that he is um
ex-services so it was raised given that
the meetings are held during the day and
outside of the district might it be able
to be a joint position just something
for consideration thank you chair
[Music]
there's nothing in the Constitution to
stop that uh we see no absolutely no
reason why that couldn't go ahead so
I'll Stand down for it okay
um
I think perhaps it might be work better
as a substitute position
I don't know if that's what other
players think I think I know we we last
year did suggest a joint working
arrangement again with councilor Mr
Wilson and councilor Mrs Butcher and I
think that was rejected
for the um that Administration so I'm
sure if it was rejected I'm not sure why
to be acceptable this time
in case you wouldn't thank you chairman
it was a regretted line at the time that
we didn't pursue the idea of having two
members because uh as has been said I
believe that councilor Wilson would be
excellent
um and there's not a uh can I just say a
fact paper to put between them in terms
of uh how they would do the job so I
think one would help the other uh in
terms of continuity uh and we both can
attend I think that really shows
roxford's commitment to the armed
services I think it really is would
would endorse our commitment thank you
Mason
thank you
um I think it's an excellent idea and I
would certainly support it and if
counselor Belton would like to formally
propose it I will second that thank you
thank you in that case I would like to
propose it as a formal motion that the
position became is offered as a joint
position
this is
with pleasure
because you share hands but holds in the
back there Council Wilson
thank you chairman I was actually going
to Second it myself thank you
well
members we have a proposition before you
uh I think the decent thing is to take a
decision on this so all those in favor
[Music]
did you want to speak
so can we take extensions
are those against first please
any extension
they're working well together
member says 32-4 three abstentions no
objection so that is carried so we never
joint facility there
we had the uh the two members uh there
uh sorry I've lost my page and they were
cancer structure and uh okay sorry I say
Wilson and I think if we just write to
make sure that we are voting those two
in
so if I could ask for votes for Council
of butcher
so there's a great emotion yeah
[Music]
event for councilor s a Wilson
and then any abstentions
[Music]
right the results for that members
there's 30 votes foreign
Mr Wilson and in the principle that is
all Kerry thank you
sorry chairman could you repeat the
numbers please
the councilor Mrs butcher I'm 35 for
councilor Wilson
members we're now going to write a
general item 13 Council meetings can I
ask that members to approve the
scheduling of council meeting as as set
out the agenda for the 28th of June 2023
18th of July 2023 31st of October 2023
14th of December 2023 13th of February
2024 and the 20th of February 2024 and I
have your approval on this please
members
thank you that's uh thank you
we will now take item 14 and probably
representatives to outside bodies and
other forums and I will divide I'll
invite Mr hankin again the monitoring
officer to do his job
sorry
okay
I like I'll answer to anything within
reason
um Mr chairman I would uh bearing in
mind the complexity of the voting
arrangements and the
um seriousness of items 15 and 16. can I
move that we reorder the agendas for the
item of 15 and 16 are taken before item
14. if I have a secondary for that
agree
[Music]
ment
thank you
to the country if anything
okay
[Music]
um
right so we're now taking 15 then shall
we
've ever seen few of the uh that vote we
announced change the items
I think we've got 15 of them are great
and our last Specialist Team it's in the
chief executive if he wishes to make
these comments
[Music]
thank you chairman members as you're
aware um this evening you've got an item
on the agenda charging 15 that Mr honkin
will be leaving the council at the end
of the month
um Andrew has worked within local
government 41 years and has decided to
retire at the end of May I wish him very
well and thank you for all his hard work
and supporting us at Rochester Council
in the period that's been with us
um as you're aware the council's duty to
appoint three statutory officer which is
head of paid Service uh 151 and the
monetary officer tonight we're
appointing a monitoring officer
um at recommendation 8.1 there's two
recommendations there and the
appointment is recommended of Emily
Ewell who will take on the new monetary
officer
um as in the report
I'm happy to take any questions if there
is any um on this report thank you
no questions members okay then so
members that there are two
recommendations uh recommendations set
out in paragraph eight one on page five
fifteen two of the report one that Emily
you'll be be designated as a monitoring
officer for the council and two that the
monitoring officer makes any necessary
subsequent changes to the cancerous
Constitution
I will move these recommendations from
the chair do I have a second done
cancer Rusty
right can those in favor of these raise
their hands and keep them up while the
officers can I thank you
remember that is unanimous thank you
members
members we're now moving on to our
agenda item 16 adoption of the community
staff of governance and that again I'm
calling upon Mr honkin the monitoring
officer to just introduce a report
thank you chairman uh this report has
been prepared at the request of a number
of the political group leaders who wish
to see the council adopt a committee
style of governance in summary chairman
the case of May resolve to change his
method of governance at any time by a
simple majority vote however the change
can only come into effect at an annual
council meeting
the center for governance is scrutinally
strongly recommend recommends that there
is a period of a minimum of six months
between making the decision to change
government's models and its
implementation
this is to enable sufficient time to
make the required constitutional
amendments to agree have a model will
work in practice for example the number
and size of committees and for the
necessary training for officers and
members to operate in the new model
there are four recommendations in the
report
firstly to agree to change the committee
system and then to initiate the
necessary pieces of work to support that
change
this includes asking the Constitutional
working group to make recommendations to
full Council on the committee structure
a review of cancer allowances to fit for
new governance arrangements and
instructions of monitoring officer to
redraft the Constitution to fit the
committee system in Constitution sorry
in consultation with the Constitutional
constitutional working group
all of these items will be brought to
full Council for agreement
if a recommendations are agreed tonight
the council will be asked to appoint to
the constitute constitutional working
group at its next meeting in June
German I'm happy to answer any questions
do you have a question
I actually have a statement
if I'm a chairman
I would ask this Council
to consider with caution what they are
about to embark on in voting to return
to a committee system of local
government
I myself have had no experience of this
but I have asked the advice of those
counselors who are members prior to 2007
what their experience was and I feel it
appropriate to share that advice with
newer members
first and foremost the concept of that
committee system
will be more democratic may not be the
case as perceived
the officers will prepare the agendas
and reports and give direction for the
Committees to decide
whilst the committee chairman will have
no this real decision-making powers
there will be no real accountability as
all committees will be amorphous and by
their very nature unaccountable
the workload for members will increase
as necessity for decision making makes
that essential
through the experiences of previous
members I have spoken with
this extra workload very rarely produces
the outcomes required at a pace that is
often required
with more decisions being delayed due to
calendar problems in fixing suitable
committee dates
the scenario we will witness will be
less member control of the council and
far greater officer control of the
council its agendas Direction and
steering regarding decisions to be made
if the committee system is adopted as it
is likely to be this evening the
officers Often by necessity and default
due to time constraints we will need to
rush agreements through the various
committees often with scant scrutiny by
members who are often worn out by
paperwork and continual Council meetings
every evening
this is the future you will embark on
where you will agree to anything to get
home and get a good night's sleep
and because of that you will delegate
the officers to run the council as that
will be an easy option for all concerned
I have worked over the last couple of
years with many of the officers since
the one team was established and I have
the utmost respect for both their
integrity and ability
the members need to go into this
decision with their eyes wide open as to
the potential outcomes which may not be
as they would hope but whatever the
outcome I will still continue to be an
active member of this Council advocating
on behalf of my residence thank you
chairman
chairman you've asked me to just clarify
something at that point of this report
we were asking for questions and we were
not over any points of clarity that are
required to me once we have dealt with
those we will ask for a proposal and the
second day of the recommendations within
here and then will come the time for
debate
so we're taking questions so have you
anybody questions cancer Lefty
thank you chair
um first two
um decision
with the
working group to be formed
now what's been said earlier this
evening with
um democracy and or to be part of the
council together
how will working group be filmed would
it be parts
um hope you'll be across the whole
council with all political parties
because this seems to be the most
important thing
with the composition and the terms of
reference where hopefully Council Ward's
questions will be put at ease
and I'm not against this I just want
more information
[Music]
uh chairman of the
constitutional worker group is a worker
group so therefore it doesn't have to be
pro-writer but the intentions are that
it is uh but it is represented by all
parties across the uh the council and
the details of that membership how many
will be in it will be coming to the next
meeting of the council
okay
[Music]
um thank you chairman just a quick
question really does accepting
recommendation one lock us into a
committee system from 20 May 2024
even though we have zero knowledge of
cost impact at this point
german yes recommendation is is clear
but the committee System model of
governance is adopted by Rochford
district council with the effect from
the annual council meeting in May 2024
obviously the important thing is that
there is a constitution constitutional
working group which will be formed from
across the council who will be able to
have input into what that looks like and
also the finer details will come back to
the council but recommendation is the
adoption of the committee system
foreign
thank you I think this is sort of
question as opposed to part of the
debate that will come next but my
question is we're being asked and in
recommendation one two
um adopt the committee system now albeit
it doesn't have to be adopted until six
months before May 2024 and we're being
asked to adopt it without a fair amount
of the questions that need answering now
we've got multiple committee meetings
before then we have recommendation too
regarding the Constitutional working
group which makes perfect sense to me I
just it feels recommendation one is
premature because we don't have all of
the answers and we're actually making
the decision five or six months prior
than we need to and I'm certainly not
against a committee system based on the
report that I've read although councilor
ward has raised some very interesting
points that I wasn't aware of and hadn't
considered but that just strengthens the
the question should we wait until one of
the next four Council meetings
um to make such a decision on
recommended one
so the question is why do we need to do
it tonight and not within the next six
months if that's easier thanks
uh chairman I could repeat again but you
know this is a recommendation which is
being put forward uh you know obviously
you you are able to do whatever you wish
to do with that particular
recommendation but that is a
recommendation which is look forward to
you tonight
thank you Gemma just by word
clarification could we make an
adjustment to our constitution to be
able to do it at another time other than
the annual council meeting
um because what I'm hearing is valid
reasons but but I also accept the points
that the administration may want may not
want to defer it for effectively two
years if you can only do it at the
annual Council
um I understand that point but it would
be quite nice if through a considered
debated process we could do it
Beyond uh 2024 so that we're not
actually rushing the uh the
consideration of the the process thank
you Jim
foreign
[Music]
thank you chairman um
as one of the members who put this
forward
and I'll switch to be at this meeting
tonight
I
I understand your the questions which
are coming about why you're doing it now
however it's quite long established that
we may vote for this today but there's a
six-month rule where it could be brought
back again so even if you are voting for
it now it it could be reversed later or
when it goes to the council it could be
voted against then as well so it isn't
as hard and stone as you think it is
um on the basis that most of the
questions seem to be around that area
and it might be nice to move to Dubai
can I propose that we accept the
recommendations
for that
transformation
right I've been advised yeah so we're
now open up the debate on we've got a
proposition and a second though so we're
now open for debate on that proposition
Okay so
Gemma with respect I thought I asked a
question and I was really looking for
some legal guidance from officers rather
than uh Council hoy's uh useful
intervention thank you
any other questions before we take a
vote
oh I'm sorry Mrs base
[Music]
thank you chair it's not a question I
would just like to say that
having been through in review of The
Constitution is a lengthy process it's a
difficult process
and yes this if this decision was made I
don't think it can be made I think it
has to be made at NL Council but if it
was made as a later date
then we wouldn't have the time to put
the quality of work in that we need to
what we what this Council needs to do
and what the proposal is is so that we
have a whole year to put a very detailed
and considered a proposal forward and as
councilor Hoyt has pointed out
the council has the right to change its
mind if that detail then becomes
inadequate but I do think that we need
to go ahead with this it's something
that I think the
residents certainly the ones I speak to
would like because it's easy to
understand it is I have to set Council
Awards point that it is I've seen a
security system in action I've been on
the council not on the council at that
time but are observed enough to say it
is more lengthy but is also tremendously
more democratic
so thank you
yes guys sorry
I'll pushing back there nothing's
happening but obviously want to say
something
um yes thank you
um with the advantage of our committee
system that doesn't give a voice
particularly when you've got minority
parties
does give advice when you've got
minority parties and at the moment we
have an mou
and a proportional committee system has
got that Advantage I mean are we saying
that the old cabinets are system was in
fact a dazzling success so uh
not my view is that this is something we
should be seriously looking at and
should progress with the recommendation
tonight thank you thank you
cash award
thank you very much chairman
um I would like to have a recorded vote
on this and I would like each item to be
taken separately I'm very conscious of
the fact that some of us are going to
feel that we're voting blind on some of
these items because we haven't got
enough information
that is my biggest concern thank you Jim
tomorrow
yeah
German sorry I just needed to look this
up in instance in the first instance and
that I'm looking to deal with cancer
wouldn't uh question
it is silence but the governance
arranges but what it says is that annual
Council will actually deal with changes
to committees uh and some committees in
the terms of Russians for them so I
think from that you could say that your
Constitution actually requires uh but
this is done at annual council meeting
so it is within the Constitution and I
think actually what your question was
could we amend the Constitution so that
it wasn't and so if the answer to that
from what I see here is yes you could
happy birthday
[Music]
thank you chairman
um I I just
in a sense going back to my audio
question is this an irrevocable decision
irrespective of the outcomes of cost for
example where we see a comparison
between the cost of the current system
and the cost of the new system at some
point in the future
and all the other matters that have been
raised
here and we are now into the debate
Arena but uh I would suspect any
business case and the details of this to
actually include the course you know I
think that will be a very important
element of this
put your hand up
sir I thought councilor Mr Mason was
indicating before me
I'm happy to go before councilman
station
um
just coming back to this I I can
understand concerns from Members who've
operated onto the cabinet system for
many years and it's
supposed advantages
I have campaigned for 10 12 years to
have a committee system in this Council
um our residents are quite well aware of
the
pros and the cons if you like off such a
system we've we've put them in leaflets
over the years
I
I have researched this myself I
this is not going to be a working party
which just sits it's all down together
to go through it I've I've asked about
having assistance from perhaps the LGA
or other bodies around this
this is a this is a serious subject and
must we must get it right there are
there are cabinet system there are
committee systems are trained from
something very close to a cabinet system
down to a to to what you might consider
much maybe a much Freer committee system
and it's up to us
at all to decide what's best for this
Council I think
when you have this number of
different groups
on a council
and I don't see that changing much
I I think it's been shown in other
Council that that the committee system
would work much better it gives
councilors much more say
over what happens within the council and
I hope that we as councils are strong
enough that we make make it and keep it
a member LED Council so I understand the
points Council of wolves making but I
think
this is the first step and we want
everybody involved and we want critical
thought as well as positive thought and
so I'll welcome that because we've got
to get it right and without the people
criticizing it we could get it wrong so
that that's what I want to say but I'll
be supporting all four motions thank you
[Music]
you wanted to speak
thank you chairman I'm not sure my voice
is going to hold out but let's have a go
um
I'm grateful to councilor Ward having
raised those issues with past members of
the council
those who would have been on the council
before 2007.
um we could have had a chat councilor
Ward because you may not have recall I
was actually elected in 2000. and I
serve continuously to 2019.
so I have had experience of both of both
systems and more particularly in the
first two years of my term on the
council it was an NOC Council and that
NOC Council worked as well as it could
and probably better if then if there had
been a cabinet system in place
in other words the committee system
benefited the NOC
we've had to do some very
um
clever thinking some open thinking
creative thinking around how we run an
Administration that jointed ministration
no less
in in an NOC situation
it's been we've we've been through every
single hoop that anyone could ever have
imagined
uh
I think it would have been much easier
had there been a committee system I know
so because I was there and I've been
there before on a personal basis I've
got to tell you that
um for the first
six or seven years of my time on the
council I was I was a was a single
member and I had a great deal of
involvement through the committee system
in all sorts of issues nothing was
related back to an executive where I
couldn't make the decision I couldn't
have a boat
and the benefits have been laid out in
the summary for the report that Mr
honkin has put before us
so I take your point Council award
um when it comes to getting evidence
about how a committee system has worked
in luxury District Council I will be I
will be very happy to give that evidence
to the working party
I I would be happy to not be directly
involved in the decision making but
actors act as a act as a witness to to
answer questions honestly and openly
about how it was and how it was
afterwards
okay
so I see personally
the benefits of the committee system and
I shall be supporting the four
recommendations
I agree completely with
councilor Hoy who reminds us that
even within the executive system
certainly within the committee system
there is a very wide range of structures
that can that can be employed
we have to examine those
we have to examine the costs we have to
examine the benefits we have to involve
our residents who behind me I know are
saying don't stop
make sure this opportunity to examine
the committee system against the
executive system do it please make sure
it happens
we are the custodians of that decision
we have to give it our all to ensure
that we make the right decision about it
we have the mechanism within the
recommendations to do so
and we have the time
it is going to be number one on the list
of things we wish to achieve as an
Administration by the end of this year
we won't shirk it I know you won't
either
so
with the joint Administration
as I spoke earlier when I was elected
leader
is firmly in favor
of the committee Style
system and as such we will wish to see
the recommendations go through tonight
to give us the opportunity to do this
work thank you
members I think we've we've discussed
this at some length really I mean we
could go backwards and forwards on
opinions really
um at the stage we are now we do have
this opportunity to look at it and
reevalue it
I'll give you the last opportunity
that's kind of you chairman thank you
very much indeed look I'll say the
outset I have absolutely no fixed view
on this and I don't think anyone should
have any fixed view because we're
waiting to hear what the details of what
this proposal entitles
my personal view is I think it's not a
bad idea I think it's quite a good idea
uh especially in a council with no
overall control so I will come off the
fence and say that my perception of it
is a good idea
but then when I look at the report
itself it talks about at least six
months between the decision to change
governance models and the implementation
date
how can you make a decision until you
know the implications of that decision
and the detail of it
I listen to the leaders formation of the
administration tonight and my perception
that I could be corrected is that it may
be a more expensive Administration than
the one that the conservative
Administration ran previously
I look at recommendation one
and I just I've heard clarification from
officers that actually we're not bound
for the year prescription
um and I would have indeed been
concerned if this had drifted on for two
years just because of a commitment under
the Constitution but we've heard tonight
that we can vary that so for that reason
um I see no reason why we can't extend
it but I'm not just talking about
procrastinating uh indefinitely I'm
talking about
um a proper structured process in the
words of these recommendations
recommendations can't come forward until
about December 2023 earlier if possible
I'm fully in favor of getting to a stage
where we can debate this even earlier
than December 2023
the independent remuneration panel
it's about time that there was a review
of members allowed to use in any case
because there's a normal four-year
interval between incremental drift so
that is one heading then of course
there's the other heading of what would
the remuneration panel say in the event
of a committee system and what would
they say in the event of a cabinet
system so I think we need to understand
what the terms of reference are on on R3
and then of course if you look at R4 it
talks about March 24 and
um for the reasons that I've said I just
think it would be nice to give ourselves
the option if it can be agreed at annual
Council next year and and you know it
regresses I've got absolutely no problem
with that and I don't believe my group
would have but I just think these are
far too tight and it would be normal
practice to actually fully understand
the implications of the committee system
which I repeat in Broad terms I think I
favor uh but I'll leave it there thank
you Jim
hmm
cancelable the uh we need to get on with
this and to look at opposition I
understand we need a fifth of members
for a recording vote do you ever fifth
to fits the membership
for this yeah recorded
[Music]
that position is carried we'll have a
thank you
right members we have nominations and
we've had a second now we're now take a
vote
I'll record it though on the
recommendations as per item 16.
that is all the items on the agenda
thank you
chairman
I point forward I'm not quite clear are
we voting on all four items together or
independently
separately
members to clarify this then our members
happy to take this all-in-one sitting or
to take each item
please
so members uh recommendation one
counselor Mrs Belton uh for against
George stain
councilor booth
full
councilman Mrs Brewer
councilor Mrs butcher
councilor Carter
councilor constable
um
counselor Crips
Council across four
councilor FD four
councilor Eaves four
councilor Foster
councilor Mrs Gadsden
hansler Gooding for
all right
council Mrs Gooding for
councilor Hoy
councilor Lamborn
cancer Lawman or
councilor Linden
councilor Mrs Mason
councilor Elliot Mason
Pastor John Mason
[Music]
councilman for
counselor James Newport
councilor Leicester Newport
[Music]
council Mrs page for
handsome Mrs Shaw
councilor sparing
up stay
councilor Mrs Squires Coleman
councilor Stanley or cancer Steptoe
councilor Ward
councilor Williams four
okay councilor Mr Wilson
cancer Mrs Wilson
abstain
right remember so that's a recording
though is 24 4 and 11 abstain none
against so that is carried
item too
recommendation to
councilor Mrs Belton fourth
councilor booth
councilor Mrs Brewer
cancer Mrs butcher
councilor Carter
councilor constable
councilor Crips
councilman cross
councilor FD
four
councilor Eaves
councilor Foster
council Mrs Gadsden
councilor Mr Gooding
handsome this is good for
cancer
Lamborn
councilor Lawman for
councilor Linden
councilor Mrs Mason for
councilor Elliott Mason
councilor John Mason
councilor Milne
cancer Newport
councilor Lisa Newport
Kansas page for
cancer Mr Shaw
hence the sparing for
as to Mrs Squires Coleman
henceless Stanley or that's the Steptoe
Council award for councilor Williams
four
that's the Mr Wilson
Mrs Wilson
before
yeah
remember that item is 34 4 no against
and one of stone that's fast
okay
maybe through an outside item 3D
independent remuneration panel yep
Mrs council Mrs Belton four
councilor booth
councilor Mrs Brewer
Kansas butcher
this one councilor Carter
councilor constable
counselor Crips
councilor cross
counselor FD for
councilor Eaves
councilor Foster
councilor Mrs Gadsden
councilor Mr Gooding or handsome Mrs
Gooding Paul
councilor hoy
cancer lamborgh
Council Lawman or councilor Linden
council Mrs Mason
councilor Elliot Mason
councilor John Mason
councilman
councilor Mr Newport
Council this is Newport
[Music]
council Mrs page for
council Mrs Shaw
cancer sparing for council Mrs Squires
Coleman
that's the Stanley
that's the step two
capsu Ward four Pastor Williams four
councilor Mr Wilson
councilman Mrs Wilson
councilor Watson four
members that's uh 35 for not against the
knife extension so that's carried
but now take item for the monitoring
officer in consultation the Constitution
working group
documentation for cancer Mrs Dalton
abstain
councilor booth
councilor Mrs Brewer
councilor Mrs butcher
councilor quarter
councilor constable
councilor Crips
Council across or councilor FD
four
councilor Eaves
councilor Foster
council Mrs Gadsden
Council Mr Gooding
council Mrs Gooding for councilor Floyd
has Lamborn
cancer Lawman
councilor Linden
Mrs Mason
cancer Elliott Mason
councilor John Mason
councilor Mill
Council Mr Newport
councilor Mrs Newport
council Mrs page for cancer Mrs Shaw
cancer sparing abstain council Mrs
Squires Coleman
cancer Stanley
cancer SEPTA
or councilor Ward Stein
councilor Williams for
Council Mr Wilson
Mrs Wilson
councilor Watton abstain
remember the result of that vote is 25
for a chain of extinctions and at none
again so let's carry it
thank you
membership haven't done finished with
that item to take you back to the item
14 the agenda item 14.
um
it does talk about a discussion
thank you chairman um referring to
councilor Christine Mason's earlier
point in the complexity of the voted of
item 14 and given that it's 10 to 10 I
would put forward a motion to defer this
item to the next four council meeting
I was about to just bring that well
[Music]
thank you chairman there's just one
minor Point uh with regards to the um
outside body committee for the London
South End airport airport Consulting
committee uh I actually represent Essex
County Council on it and I know that
there is a meeting tomorrow at 1 45.
so can I suggest chairman that perhaps
you take that particular one
um as you've got a little bit of time so
those members that are nominated on it
can attend the meeting tomorrow and if
they so wish to do so and either gender
I'm quite happy to make sure that they
get the necessary paperwork
did yeah
the chairman if I can uh just uh comment
on that in that so it was known a few
weeks ago that we'd have a meeting
tomorrow obviously you have a number of
nominations for that particular one here
which take some time to go through but I
think the decision was made at that time
that there wouldn't be Representatives
or brochure at tomorrow's meeting
because nobody would have actually had
the time to have read the papers but if
I've uh if you wish to then obviously
you can
okay
sorry Sherman can you just carry for
that can you confirm that you're saying
that the meeting is going to add if we
don't nominate now we we will not be in
attendance
for that meeting I mean if that is the
case I think on library for counselor um
with councilor Steptoe and I think we
should at least nominate for that
meeting I can attend tomorrow at 1 45 no
problem
points of older missionary chairman are
we voting to extend the meeting or not I
think that's what we was
uh just revised of him at the point of
all rashmir I've I'm actually going to
bring up the idea of an extension so at
that point of order is already that's
what we're discussing here to see where
we're going with this one because the
time is pressing thank you
meeting is tomorrow I know that officers
haven't had time to uh brief members on
that but I do take uh councilor Hawaii's
uh Point as well and he is one of the
nominations on here but we are asking we
have five nominations for three
appointments and it will take some time
to actually do that for one meeting
tomorrow
I'm going to read you to you that
members the meeting is now lasted
roughly two hours so we will shortly
take a 10 minute route Comfort break
first though I would like to move a
motion without notice according to
committee procedure rule nine in to
extend the meeting Beyond two and a half
hours for as long as practical in order
to complete the visits right I was gonna
say have I got a second done
right yeah
I'm afraid that we're gonna have to
defer this other item to the next
Council so that we could discuss it
another time
awesome
sorry chairman I was going to propose
that we extend the council business just
to deal with the item of appointing
nominees for London Southend airport
consultative committee
that would appear to be urgent I'd also
like to add on on rather surprisingly in
two weeks of discussions with officers
this was never brought up
so it might push us into this position
of taking a decision about extending
this meeting so well you've said no so
you know I mean we've got to make a
point
they need to vote need to vote they need
to vote we needed a vote to extend
otherwise point of order yeah I believe
under the Constitution you're required
to have a second there if I heard
correctly you didn't actually get a
second to your proposal so actually the
proposal Falls doesn't it that's that's
basically a Cancer woman that's what I
was saying really that we haven't got a
vote so we would have extended if we at
the boat sorry put a proposal forward to
extend the meeting for the duration
of having everything it takes to decide
the nominees for the outside body of
London South End airport consultative
committee all I need is a second class
and we could just do that I second that
chairman thank you
okay so we come back Council as we come
back to the issue about extension now
we've got a choice here if we take a
vote on it and you turn that vote down
for extinctions that puts pay to any
decision to further go any desire to do
so I'm pretty much
can I offer a solution because this will
take some time again you've all had to
note there about how to do the voting
and you'll have to go through a vote of
all five for the first uh seat or four
for the second seat or three you see
where I'm coming from with regards to
this uh we were just discussing this and
wondering you know we have a nominations
here or we have members here is there
anybody who wishes to attend on behalf
of the Rochford District Council
tomorrow and if there is then we could
just agree that for the one meeting
tomorrow
that to me makes sense
how's your stepco you brought it up did
you either wanted to yeah
chairman now I am already a member of
the ACC as a representative for Essex
County Council so uh I'm quite happy to
represent Roger if you so wish if the if
the councils wish me to do that and
recall back but I don't really think
that is correct
cash Ahoy
so I was just saying I'd be willing to
attend tomorrow
[Music]
occasionally I'm sure
she also helpful members who have not
actually been appointed to the committee
actually go to the committee meeting
it must be if they're doing that it's
got to be the members that are already
on the committee members that have not
been elected cannot go on it we have now
voted for an ex not to have an extension
and I suggest we all go home and do this
at the next meeting thank you
chairman I would like to promote a
motion to
to go forward with
um
the vote I've proposed it and there was
a second before it and I think we we
should just vote
Miss
putt so we saved time we've got to
propose at the second instead of
debating it let's vote on it very much
I'm gonna I'm gonna put my position in
this we've now gone past our closing
time I did ask if you wanted to extend
this meeting and there was a no
but as far as I'm concerned about the
situation
Mr chairman if I can clarify you did
suggest it but there was no second deal
so
um can we please I've asked correctly
against the Constitution that you have a
motion on the table which has been
seconded and I've asked it to be put
when that is asked it should be affected
fourth week thank you
I was trying to second that motion and
nobody you all ignored me so
so maybe sitting at the back here
now it's becoming a bit of a
free-for-all I'm gonna put my foot down
here we're gonna have to come to a
conclusion on this one we have a extend
this meeting or we close the meeting and
it's as simple as that
and we didn't have a second
I was trying to secondly you ignored me
chairman with greatest respect
um it's now two minutes past ten and I
think we're out of time in any case
right
members
the motion was put forward councilor
Lamborn apparently anything
so well you've got a choice if you say
no on a vote then it's a no we can't
back down in Circus I'm telling you
so both
times
but we've got an extension
and this item will go on to the next
meeting so in accordance with that then
um
that's it
um the conclusion of the business then
is now I've gone worse nearly five past
ten and I want to thank you all for
being here and we'll deal with this
other issue at the next meeting and so
members of the audience and members of
the council please be upstanding whilst
the chairman and chief executive retired
from the meeting
[Music]
thank you
members of the public can you please
make your way out of the hall and out of
the building by the main entrance thank
you all for your attendance
[Music]
foreign